foreign
omian time algorithm for the free energy
of one-dimensional quantum systems in
the thermodynamic limit
this is joined work with hamzan Omar
fawzi and you can find the full version
of our work on the archive
let me also thank the organizers of itcs
2023 for giving us the opportunity to
present our work here
a stop is introducing the setup of our
problem if you're interested in
multi-parted Quantum systems so you can
think of like atoms aligned on a chain
and each of these atoms has some degree
of freedom for example by an electron
which has a spin degree of Freedom or
something like that we model each of
these local systems by a d dimensional
Hilbert space
and thereby the whole system has a
tensor product of these local Hilbert
spaces which is then a multi-party fluid
space of Dimension D to the N where n is
the number of particles that we have in
our chain
okay
um we'll later on take this number of
particles to Infinity this will actually
not come up in calculations later on
also we assume this is actually how we
use the geometry of this chain that
interactions are just local so there
will just be nearest labor interactions
between two neighboring particles think
of something like an energy penalty term
for spins that are not aligned in a
ferromagnet something like that
as we assume our system to be
translational variant we will only have
one of these interactions which is then
repeated on each neighbor pair of
neighboring sites
since action term is given by a complex
formation Matrix H which is in a d
squared times D Squared Matrix because
at X on two sides
so I'm returning of the whole system on
N sides is then given by a sum of all
these neighboring interaction terms so
you sum up
um the first and second second and third
interaction and so on
and you're playing a d to the N times D
to the N Matrix each of systems is
basically
also deeps the N times due to the N
Matrix but acting correctly on a number
of sites then acting on two sides and
then acting as the identity again as
remaining sites
as these terms are just always acting on
two sides the whole Matrix is actually
sparse
it's a quantity we're interested in is
the free energy
it's given by the following formula you
first compute
the exponential of
um
the hamiltonians that we just mentioned
times the inverse temperature but it has
the inverse temperature
and take a trace of that
this exponent this trace of the
exponential is also called the partition
functions at
afterwards take a logarithm multiply by
temperature and normalize by the system
size so system size as we said
beforehand will be taken to Infinity
which is a thermodynamic limit
foreign
Matrix is no longer necessarily sparse
so it's not efficient to just compute
this in N because the size of this
Matrix will grow exponentially with n
and that's basically what um determines
the computational time you need to
compute this quantity here if you do it
straightforwardly but just
um linear algebra computations
I also want to introduce a thermal State
um which is the state describes the
system if you have a physical system at
a certain given temperature
um one over beta
it's basically also this is exponential
again times the normalization factor
and the reason why we're interested in
the free energy is that it gives access
to similar Dynamic observables these are
basically you take some hermitian
operators acting on the side times the
sum of state and the trace of it this
gives you the expectation value of the
observable O So any physical quantities
like energy magnetization and heat
capacity is not in this form but you can
also derive it from other observables
so you can compute all these quantities
either by having access to the thermal
state but also directly by taking some
derivatives of this function f beta of H
with respect to parameters you have to
introduce basically adding The Observer
to the parameter H and taking the
derivative with respect to this and
gives you access to similar observables
so if you're able to compute F you're
able to compute basically anything you
don't want to know physically about this
m system in its thermal state
also not just relevant in our work but
in general the free energy sometimes
that's not no electricity and these are
called phase Transitions and also
physically interesting
this way of introducing the free energy
as a log partition function is a bit
more combinatorial
an alternative formulas given as follows
you can instead again Define the free
energy as a limit of the system size
going to infinity and normalized by the
system size so actually it's a free
energy density and for each system size
you minimize this functional which is
for a given physical state gives you the
energy of the State minus the entropy
times the temperature so for low
temperatures high beta you're basically
just minimize the energy
and for increasing temperatures you will
try to maximize the entropy of the
system
the minimization is you're taking over
all states which are positive seven
different matrices with which are
normalized
and to minimize that of this formula can
be easily figured out is just the
thermostat and reduced in the previous
slide
um and as I just said if you take the
limit beta to Infinity you actually
obtain the ground set energy which is a
related problem to the free energy
this is also interesting because the
ground set problem is known to be qmx
part to compute so not even by a quantum
computer we expect to be in general be
able to compute the ground state energy
as I've been proof of my code is my in
Irani and this actually means when we
look at algorithms to create the free
energy whatever we do
these algorithms will not be expected to
be efficient in the beta because if
there were you could just use them to
just compute the free energy for a high
beta and thereby compute and approximate
the ground state energy so we will not
expect to be efficient in beta in
particular
as long as these two complexity classes
qma x and x are not the same it is not
possible to get a polynomial runtime in
beta for free energy approximation
foreign
so with this in mind we are able to look
at the main result of our work which is
an algorithm to beautify energy at a
fixed temperature
the algorithm text's inputs this
interaction Matrix described by this um
CD squared times D Squared Matrix
um
and these interaction matrices are
assumed to be Norm no bigger than one
otherwise you could just include the
beta dependency in the h
furthermore what we take sectional input
of the algorithm it's the accuracy that
we want to achieve with the algorithm so
some number greater zero and the
actually interesting thing is we have no
system size and there's just one Matrix
described as interaction it's actually
interesting thing is how does the
complexity of the algorithm scale versus
accuracy we want to achieve
um the output of the algorithms are
obviously uh estimation and
approximation of free energy up to
accuracy Epsilon
and the runtime is then given by this a
bit bulky expression and exponentially
in the logarithm of one of Epsilon
divided by log log 1 repsilon what you
can see is this Factor here improves
slightly Upon A just polynomial runtime
in one of our episodes so that's why we
have a sub polynomial runtime in the
inverse era
this is also the Improvement compared to
the best previous work for computing the
free energy which is a runtime and which
is polynomial in one rep so where C is
just some fixed constant even growing
quite um quickly with the temp inverse
temperature
this is a work from kuvahara and Saito
um an additional advantage of our
algorithm is that it's quite simple to
implement we will look at the actual
algorithm a bit later where we can see
it's just a very simple linear algebra
computation for certain
um linear maps that you have to write
down which we will consider later
also has already mentioned this only
holds at fixed temperature and if you
would write down this runtime including
the beta dependence we would find so
it's doubly exponential in beta but as
we said we don't expect an efficient
algorithm in beta because it would solve
computationally hard ground set problem
furthermore in the introduction I
mentioned how you can compute the
terminal and expectation values and just
using the free energy and you could do
this by just using this algorithm in a
black box way but it will turn out
actually the algorithm gives the side
result just an immediate description of
margins of the thermostat which you can
then directly use to compute like some
expectation values and other things
also as I just mentioned as our
algorithm it's quite simple to implement
we also did this and tried it out on a
on a toy hamiltonian here's the XY
hamiltonian
this is the interesting thing about sex
but I'm returning for us was basically
just that it's um as an analytic
solution so we could actually just
obtain an analytical expression for the
summer expectation values and free
energy in the thermodynamic limit
directly and compared to those four
showing how well our algorithm works
thereby these error rates that you can
see here in these graphs are actually
computed compared to the analytic
solution they're not the error bounds we
get from our proof which are would be a
bit worse
um what you can see is also actually in
practice it works quite well for here
example for example for the Fairly high
temperatures but not too high
temperatures you get down to machine
precision and in the computation of the
free energy
all these data points basically lq
describes more or less the runtime of
the algorithm but even for the largest
runtime and the largest runtime it just
took a few seconds to complete each data
point
also the error actually at some point
can drop to zero because we don't know
whether algorithm of the lower upper
bound so just happens at some point
possibly
and that's the error crosses zero
also here you can see this as mentioned
this parameter L basically describes the
runtime the runtime will scale
exponentially with l
and you can see here how the error
decreases with this parameter describing
the runtime
um to get an idea of how we prove this
result we first look at the classical
case which is actually considerably
simpler
but it really gives some intuition of
how the quantum case works as well
when I say classic case what I mean is
this interaction Matrix is diagonal
so instead of describing
um this is complex formation Matrix we
just look at these values on the diagram
these are just real numbers here
um describing the energies that you have
for any sort of neighboring
configuration so this numbers h11 is if
two neighboring sites are both in state
one and up to State D you describe all
these interaction Energies
um this replaces the formula with the
trace of the exponential of these um
hamiltonians by this formula here we
just look at the petition function it's
a logarithm effect time factor which
gives us the free energy
and what you have you have this sum this
is exponential of sum over numbers
instead of a trace you just sum over all
possible configurations of the system
this means as opposed to the quantum
case these are just commuting terms and
you can just take this exponential apart
and treat all these and terms separately
this also means the summation of a
stress applies to two of these terms
particularly if you consider each of
these terms to be a matrix
um in the indices J1 and J2
then you just have to sum of these
indices to make a matrix multiplication
so all this calculation
it's just a different way of writing out
a matrix multiplication
and the last sum would give you a trace
and
because this Matrix T here the transfer
Matrix this is actually in solar
computation as a well-known trick called
the detecting of transformation
statistical mechanics
um and if you look how this what this
computation actually turns out to be you
basically just have to sum overall
eigenvalues of symmetrics t
m to the power of n
if you then do actually the semi Dynamic
limit so it takes the system size to
Infinity logarithm versus quantity it's
the only eigenvalue that contributes is
the spectral radius
um so in fact the whole computation of
the partition function in classical
cases just takes this transfer Matrix
write it down compute its spectral
radius and then you're basically done
and have computed the free energy up to
some
um logarithm and normalization Factor
um
the even more convenient thing is this
largest eigenvalue will be equal to the
spectral radius by the Performing theory
that is because the transfer Matrix only
has positive entries because these
varieties exponentials M of some real
numbers
okay
um as I said then you just do a small
computation this is minus one over beta
logarithm of some um maximal eigenvalue
of this Matrix to get the free energy
and you can also obtain the marginals of
the summer state in this computation
here to the correspond to the maximum
eigenvalue you have a corresponding
eigenvector and the entries of this
eigenvectors basically
um the probability distribution of a
one-side margin of solid state if you
want to have several sides of this
marginal you can just multiply by the
transfer Matrix
to obtain these as well so you can also
compute and several side and some
expectation values easily
this all works because classical thermal
states are Markov networks or in 1D
Markov chains this is by the harmlessly
Clifford theorem that yeah
see skip States
um of some states are just equivalent to
Markov networks or Markov chains in 1D
so this is motivation in mind let's now
have a look at the quantum case
so Quantum case is a lot different for
example this Markov property I just
mentioned does no longer holds in the
quantum case
um you will have something similar
called an approximate Quantum Market
Markov property but it would be much
harder to use immediately for this
computation
and also this was mentioned direction as
we have to
free energy for classical systems
basically computed independently of beta
you can also get the ground state energy
of classical systems easily but we
actually know on the other hand that in
this Quantum case ground set problems Q
May X part
um so the whole complexity of of the
quantum system is way more difficult
than the classical case
um today we take some inspiration from
this classification case and try to
write something down similar to the
transfer Matrix in the classical case
um which turns out to be a lot more
complicated object and which is given
here
um but you have you have a matrix
multiplication where you take the an
input um state
multiply things that look a bit like
thermal States or inverses of thermal
States from both sides and then shift
the system by one side
um this is what we call the
non-community differential Matrix and it
has been introduced by Iraqi
um in 1969 already
what he used it for was to prove the
analyticity of free energy and there was
the absence of phrase transitions in 1D
um what he actually considers is not
only this map but he takes the limit of
this um number L going to Infinity
as you can see with the number L's these
matrices sizes grow so actually
and this limit is a map from an infinite
dimensional space to an infinite
dimensional space and would not actually
help us with Computing spectral radii or
writing an actual algorithm
nevertheless in this limit and with a
certain notion of C star algebraths and
States on on sister algebra he could
proves that eigenvalue and eigenvectors
of this map correspond to free energy
and some mistake but just if it takes a
limit of the snap
so the idea for us is then what can we
do if we just consider finite
dimensional maps in particular this
perhaps written down here
to their
um spectral radii converge to the
spectral radius of the limit map
and also what about the corresponding
eigenvector assignment
um the technical tool we use for that is
also taken from Iraqi is basically these
factors here which correspond to again
let's consider the classical case
and you take something like a thermostat
and then basically it's inverse but on
one side Less in the classical case
where these matrices commuters would
just cancel and you basically recover
the classical transfer Matrix
in the quantum case this is no longer
true but still if Texas parameter to
Infinity are rocket proof that these
factors these Matrix products will
converge to something
okay
what we now want to do is we want to use
these convergence results and prove
something about
um the eigenvalues and eigenvectors of
this Matrix versus linear map
and we do this by considering an unjust
for an approximate eigenvector of the
snap
um it should be mentioned that it's not
straightforward to use standard
perturbation Theory firstly because the
snap changes Dimension with the
parameter L and also because it's not
hermitian which is what most
perturbation bounds for eigenvalues
would work for
um the answer for an approximate
eigenvector that we use is just the
thermal set or the marginal of the
thermal State on other sides
um and as we plug in into this formula
this helps us to use a variational
expression for the um specular radius
so-called collets VLAN formula
um to give estimates on the spectral
radius
given that the conversions rate proved
in Iraqi for this factor is super
exponentially fast and we were able to
also prove super exponential convergence
um of the spectral radius of l-star lmap
to the true free energy or Raza
exponential of minus beta times the true
free energy
the super exponential convergence versus
and just exponential conversions is
actually what gives us improvement in
our algorithm from polynomial time to
set polynomial time
the next thing despite the eigen value
is also the eigenvector so this again is
a has an additional problem namely just
having the conversions of spectral
radius does that immediately give you
the conversions of the corresponding
eigenvector in addition you need
something called a primitivity condition
this means that the map l-star L maps
all positive semi-definite um operators
to positive definite operators
in addition we want this in a
quantitative version so we just not only
want that it's positive definite but we
also want to lower bound its minimum
eigenvalue
this will actually Decay exponentially
with the with the number L but still we
need some bound on the convert as a the
Decay rate and also we need a bound from
what L actually this works
um when we have a quantitative
productivity condition we can use
something called perophobenius theory
for positive operators as opposed to the
one for just matrices with positive
entries
um to prove the convergence of this
eigenvector which involves also
technical tools like the helpless
projective metric in our proof
this then proves that if you do this
spectral radius calculation and just
computes the corresponding eigenvector
you immediately gets the thermostat
I mentioned the introduction you would
not actually need this because you can
just use the computation of the free
energy in a black box way computer's
derivatives to get thermal expectation
values and thereby actually also
marginals of the thermal state
but it turns out to be way more
convenient to just immediately get the
summer State as a byproduct
I will also turn it out in practice it's
a lot more efficient to compute um
correlation functions because if you
want to compute correlation functions
using derivatives
we would first have to block the system
up to the size of the correlation
function you want to compute and only
then uses derivative method which makes
the computation um way more expensive
so it's quite convenient to immediately
get a thermal State on several sites out
of the algorithm we present
because this I'm also already about to
conclude my talk
what we did in this work is we present
an algorithm to compute the free energy
and the particular case of translation
variant 1D Quantum systems in the
thermodynamic limit
and we use proof techniques to also
treat these types of systems and
improves the analyticity of free energy
in one dimension this is going from work
from Iraqi and the quantities and Maps
coming up in this work allows to allow
us to present an algorithm based on
these
turns out that our algorithm is also
particularly simple to implement and
gives quite precise results in practice
if you use it for
um 1D Quantum systems
process and put down a table here which
kind of gives us a bigger picture of how
this um
algorithmic efficiency fits into
different settings
I mentioned already in the beginning
that we have a ground state problem
which is computationally hard already in
one dimension for this specific setting
of translation array and 1D Quantum
systems
given that this already holds in 1D that
it's computationally hard to compute or
approximate the ground state energy and
this also extends to higher Dimension
directly
and this is not true for the classic
case it's just trans Quantum case
um conversely as long as you take any
finite temperature but you don't
consider the runtime with temperature
just you fix the temperature and
consider the runtime with the in with
the inverse error you want to achieve
then we do present efficient
approximation algorithms this one in sub
polynomial time and that's been previous
work bases can be done in polynomial
time in one hour Epsilon actually these
other works also allow for
non-translational variant systems in
that case it's also interesting to
consider the runtime with system size as
it doesn't come up in our setting
um in higher Dimensions they are proof
that it's computationally hard to
determine the free energy as long as
you're above some fixed finite
temperature T1 so so called critical
temperature
and where the proof actually also just
uses the classical system so in higher
Dimensions
um this computational problem is much
harder
nevertheless as long as you are above
some as another critical temperature it
must not be the same as the one in the
proof of the hardness here and it's
known that it's that there are efficient
approximation algorithms for the free
energy
again polynomial runtime in the inverse
era
if we look at this picture there might
also be some open questions for example
um if you can do this in separately
normal time in one repsilon can we
actually achieve something even better
could we get some runtime like log one
or rapson as we could do in the
classical case
for computing the free energy in 1D
or if we don't expect this to be true I
would probably not expect it to be true
then can we actually prove a hardness
result on this um computational task
also it's interesting that a similar
picture like this one holds for other
questions in many body physics and for
example like how do correlations behave
in money but many body systems or where
are occur phase Transitions and all
these actually have a similar picture
that these things can occur
um
in in ground sets of um Quantum systems
or in higher dimensional Quantum systems
but not in 1D and not at sufficiently
high temperature so it would be kind of
interesting to look at how these
questions are connected
this is I'm about to put my talk and um
thank you for your attention